despite being born quirkless Deku
eventually unlocks seven different
quirks first he inherits one for all
from all might and then he unlocks the
quirks of six former users but what if
there is still one more secret Quirk
that he has to unlock as Deku continues
to become stronger with seven quirks at
his disposal he is approaching Quirk
Singularity the point at which his
quirks become too strong for his body to
handle shigaraki already reached that
point and his body reacted by developing
mutations that allowed it to adapt to
the power and morph into its ideal form
Deku might experience a similar
transformation as his quirks get
stronger Deku May unlock a new final
form and his quirks could all fuse
together into a single super Quirk then
instead of using seven different quirks
he would use a single Quirk that
surpasses all of them individually
subscribe for more mha videos